[Music]
it's been a really wild season
and summer 2020 has been living up to
the hype by throwing at us the anime
industry's summer blockbusters one after
another it's not an exaggeration to say
that this season's chock full of
action-packed series maybe
new stars of carryovers from the
previous seasons due to various
circumstances
as we look to wrap the season up let's
go through 10 of the best fights that
the season has to offer
after all if you're someone who craves
action this season provides no shortage
of it i don't think there's any need for
a longer intro so let's begin and let
the battles do the talking
first on the list at number 10 is friend
versus yumiya
from railgun tea
railgun t's interesting broadcast
schedule has been quite documented on
this channel already and with the season
getting extended all the way to the
summer season we can have this fight on
the list who knew that a fight between
two side characters who ultimately end
up being inconsequential in the grander
scheme of the huge huge world of rail
decks would have arguably one of the
best fights in the series
i think it helps that the two characters
don't have a lot of the broken magical
powers that a lot of the rail decks
universe has so what we have here is a
strategic moor brawl
following a cat and mouse chase yet it
really does help when you don't have
world altering powers or the like and
have to resort to strategizing your
attack plans the fight's not anything
too spectacular in terms of animation
or effects like some of the fights that
we're going to see later on but i
enjoyed it for how it progressed
the execution and ultimately how it
ended
[Music]
sure knows how to make a first
impression coming into the series i got
wind of the idea that this is supposed
to be some kind of humanity versus
monsters thing and while it's largely
proven to subvert expectations as it
progressed
i think that it mostly set the pace with
its action sequences in its pilot
episode
this right here is what decadence is all
about you've got the colorful world
the vibrant characters the creative
designs for the monsters
and you've got all the fast-paced action
going on all over the place
people flying around technology showing
its metal
monsters getting blown away fast camera
cuts that keep your attention glued to
the screen
i'm telling you it's insane no wonder
people compared it to attack on titan
then again what humanity versus monster
series doesn't get compared to one of
the most enduring and captivating animes
of the previous decade
the whole sequence is chaos it's madness
but somehow i find order and rhythm in
it
it really gives me a good impression and
was a big part of me continuing on with
the series
[Music]
eighth on the list is anas versus melhes
the challenge with having a series be
all about a character who's so
ridiculously overpowered
is writing a good fight for that
character having an opponent putting up
a fight can put a damper on the main
point of the series that which is that
the main character is just
way too broken for mere mortals to
comprehend hence we often just get some
acrobatic fest like the one in tatsuya
versus masaki
or something we remember more for the
over the top effects like saitama vs
boros
on the contrary i like what they did
with the second arc of misfit of demon
king academy the main focus at least on
paper
is the battle between arnos and ley in
the tournament finals however the anime
makes an amazing transition from the
battle
which has already been pretty exciting
all things considered into the ark's
ultimate confrontation where he
showcases not only his power but the
more empathetic side of him i like how
it shows that there's something bigger
than a tournament final and i really
like how this shows the depth for our
main character
the series has always had a thing for
family dynamics and i think that this
fight in its implications are a great
way of adding personality to what can
otherwise lead into a boring main
character
[Music]
almost
[Music]
as an isakai series isn't really fight
centric more of the intrigue and the
selling point of the series can be
attributed to the mystery and the dark
atmosphere now that doesn't mean that it
can't have some great fights
as season one showcased for this season
i give the best one to the first
episode fight between rem against the
team of greed and gluttony
personally i never ranked rem to be
someone very high on the power level
scheme of things in the re zero universe
i mean she's strong and she's more than
capable but against battle tested
veterans in wilhelm or krush
or the sheer insanity of the sin
archbishops i think that she's just no
match
despite all odds she fights on clinging
onto the memories of subaru memories
that fuel her resolve
but because this is re-zero we can't
have good things and despite giving us a
spectacle of a fight with her flail
she essentially gets one shot the fight
would have been great but i feel that
it's too short nonetheless it's an
amazing way to get the story going for
the second season
having read ahead from what the anime
has as of the time of this writing i
know there's going to be a lot more
amazing fight sequences ahead
mostly featuring garfield and elsa
that's going to have to wait though but
those are certainly some cool scenes to
look forward to
with re zero season 2 being confirmed to
be a split call we'll be seeing a subaru
emilia and the rest of the gang
all the way next year
it feels nice to see that even after all
these decades one piece
still has it over the years it's had its
fair share of bad ass moments and
emotional fights that made it one of the
most beloved series of all time just
recently it had a nice little fight that
shows that even its secondary main
characters still get their much deserved
shine this deep into the run
and i wish i could say the same for a
lot of other shonen this fight's
basically about
depicting zorro as a badass we already
know that he's won before this fight but
how do you drive home the point that
this character is really strong you have
him take a page out of ken butch's
playbook and take a scythe to the chest
then have him use it as an advantage and
swing it around as a weapon for his
amazing technique for the victory it's a
pretty quick fight but the animation and
art is still
amazing and it's probably one of the
shining moments that our favorite green
head swordsman has had in recent memory
shinra vs karon finds its way to the
number five spot on this list
i've said a lot of good things about
fire forces fights and the creativity on
display in the series and the trend
seems to keep going on with its second
season
in the fourth episode of the second
season shinra runs into karon of the
white clad the whole sequence just looks
so clean
and so smooth things start off fast and
furious with a sky battle between the
two showing us that shinra has pretty
much
no option but to win the fight not that
it's going to be easy when he's taking
on caron
most notable is probably the exchange
involving the two combatants throwing
each other into walls
that and kara no selling shinra's
offense while looking down on our hero
skill
even with shinra's best hits kharon
still seemed miles ahead of him but
guess what
karen isn't even a pillar imagine what
kind of challenges lie ahead for the
good guys
four kill of five elements enters at
number four with this
bridge fight scene
i've talked about fog hill of five
elements a couple of times already now
and i think that this show is really
underappreciated there's a lot of
creativity that i can see from it and i
can tell that it's a very well crafted
and thought-out series from first
impressions alone it also boasts a
healthy resume of nice fights
made all the more noteworthy thanks to
the series unique art style it's a joy
watching the characters go
at it in this scene from the very first
episode being a scene that sets the tone
of the series i didn't expect it to have
the payoff feel for something with
history and build up but as a standalone
fight
this is probably better than a lot of
the stuff i've seen recently look out
anime industry there's a new contender
in town if you need more reasons to
watch fog hill of five elements then
make sure to check out the other videos
that cover some more scenes from the
show
links on the corner of the screen
[Music]
[Music]
so
next is this fight from white cat legend
[Music]
after fog kill of five elements we have
the next chinese anime on this list in
third place this fight pretty much
presents to us why chinese martial arts
series have been gaining traction in the
past couple of years
smooth choreography nice animation and
an art style that's similar to fog hill
all create a scene that deserves such a
high spot on the list the fight also
takes you through a roller coaster with
the sequence quickly
shifting pace with its slow downs and
focus shots it takes a special kind of
art to make you feel
each impact of the weapons blows in each
exchange but these guys have done it
with this battle
it's a shame not a lot of people have
heard of this series now that you've
seen some of the best that it has
why not give it a try
[Music]
[Music]
so
speaking of isekai that are
fight-centric the second part of sword
art online's war of underworld has a lot
of amazing fights
it's like the anime team pulled out the
remaining budget and pulled the ufo
table if you need further proof that
sao's long become
a1 pictures darling franchise and
moneymaker just look at the effort they
make in animating the sequences for war
of underworld
in terms of animation and voice acting i
can't even decide which fight to put as
seo's representative
if it comes to sheer magnitude or
emotions i give this to the final battle
between kirito and gabrielle
putting two overpowered characters who
have completely mastered the rules and
system of underworld gave us this treat
and kirito eventually gets his ass
kicked for the most part of this fight i
mean you have few options against
someone who knows sells everything with
this completely evil heart
empowered by the lucid dreamlike system
of underworld i also like how kirito
pulls off the concept of the spirit bomb
as his ultimate attack
what more powerful force in anime than
the will of all living beings in
underworld it's those prayers and help
from kirito's true eugeo
that create a force impossible for even
the god of darkness to overcome
with how the episode ended afterwards i
personally wouldn't mind it if sao as an
anime would be done for good after this
arc i mean i'm a fan and i would love
nothing in the series to end on its
thematic high as explained in my other
channel's video which you can check out
by clicking on the link on the corner of
the screen
for all the cut content and weird pacing
pretty much nothing tops god of high
school this season when it comes to the
actual spectacle of fights
look at it this way for a series that's
pretty much completely about fights and
tournaments
they better make good on those luckily
we have those in droves
i've often talked about god of high
school's great fight choreography and
praise-worthy animation but the fight
between jin and davey does more than
that i just find it so awesome because
of the raw
emotion on display i'm not sure if i'll
have to hike the actual fight because i
just want to let the video do it for you
the way the fight progresses
also cuts deep when you step back and
think of what davey is going through i
just feel sad that they cut some content
due to time constraints
however for the fight itself amazing you
have so many people talk about this
fight because it's just that good
davey's backstory his personality and
his fighting techniques come into play
to produce one of the best episodes of
the series so far the anime team had a
challenge ahead and they decided to
adapt one of the biggest webtoons around
and they passed with flying colours with
these 10 fights under the belt do you
think the summer 2020 has lived up to
the pre-release hype or not
which one is your favorite do you think
that fall 2020 would have as many great
fights to compare
leave those juicy comments and spicy
takes below with a few more weeks to go
before this season's conclusion
why not start the catch-up run while
you're at it as always if you're up for
more content like this
make sure to like subscribe and hit that
bell button on your way out
i'll see you next time
you